so I guess you guys want me to watch g8
whether it was on Twitter Instagram the
youtube comment section or even through
my editor and AJ's personal Twitter
accounts please don't do that so many of
you wanted me to cover this non-canon
part of the story that I honestly
couldn't ignore it and what's more is
after covering very large chunks of the
story in my last two videos I decided to
not rush through things at the breakneck
pace that I was and to analyze things
maybe just that little bit more
carefully just so that I don't miss
anything important or feel compelled to
glance over anything in the interest of
time I want to do this series justice
and so today I'll be plunging into and
breaking out of the surprisingly well
told story of g8 and of course I'll be
taking my first dip into the water 7
saga with the long ring long land arc
it's surprising to think that despite
being six parts deep into this series I
am still less than 33% of the way
through it already feeling like one of
the most immersive and competent stories
I've ever read and now thanks to g8
watched I'm totally not mark and this is
my first impressions thoughts on and
review for the impressive tense and
hilarious g8 and long ring long land
arcs
g-eight to be perfectly honest you'll
need to thank nexus my editor and aj for
bringing this act to my attention and
convincing me to ultimately cover it at
all I had planned on this review series
to strictly cover cannon only manga
material but given the sheer volume of
requests this arc received I simply
couldn't ignore it it feels like this
arc is immensely beloved to you all and
so I was eager to see if nothing else
what the hype was all about and
typically speaking when it comes to
filler content or material not written
by the author themselves I've always
noticed a disconnect between the toned
characters or writing of that particular
material that makes it feel wrong when
placed alongside the original usually
for me filler feels like an imitation or
a caricature of the part I love in short
I'm usually not a fan of filler arcs
primarily for the reasons I mentioned
but also the tension and stakes feel
non-existent always in the back of my
mind I'm acutely aware that nothing in
this act really matters at all and once
it's all done it'll revert back to the
status quo where it began for the sake
of continuity with the Canon material
and while GA does exactly that it
doesn't feel like a fan fiction or an
imitation but a tribute to the series
bottling everything I loved about it in
11 tightly paced well-executed episodes
the characters felt like the characters
the stakes felt believable yet not
drastic the narrative felt purposeful
contrivance was kept to a minimum and
possibly my favorite aspect of this arc
it's the absolute funniest I've ever
seen one piece I have never laughed so
hard while watching anime in all of my
life so let's look at the areas of what
I thought worked and some of the things
I thought could have been done better
let's dive into g8 oh yeah
those country
the real known the set up the set up for
this arc I both loved and didn't like
for separate reasons
I'll get the bat out of the way first
because this is the only real major
gripe with this arc I had and it's
easily ignored moving forward for me
essentially we take upright as the guy
are falling from sky Pia and the
adventure they had there however they
then land in the middle of a highly
secure naval Marine base called g8 they
make note that while their fall in the
wind pushes them off course and so they
don't know where they're falling anymore
this is when they just so happened to
land in the center of one of the most
secure naval bases in the world the
level of which I would need to suspend
my disbelief to buy that is
extraordinary it's the equivalent of
hitting a bull's-eye while riding a
motorcycle 10,000 feet in the air
the reason this bothered me more than it
might have perhaps bothered you is that
I really liked the care with which Oda
sets up his circumstances for arcs the
reason places are found by the crew have
legitimate explained reasons they don't
just happen by chance and so because
they sort of landed here randomly it
felt sort of contrived but that's just
the beginning and once we get into
things I begin to see what everyone sees
in this story once again instead of
taking the safe and predictable route of
beginning the story primarily from the
view of the protagonists GA takes his
time and shows the day-to-day activities
and lives of the crew and characters
we'll be getting to know in this journey
this particularly felt very Oda like to
me as the story didn't feel like it was
pressure to rush through plot points to
establish a goal but that's what to say
that goal doesn't become abundantly
clear either to the naval officers and
crew at the base a ship comes crashing
down to their bay completely abandoned
this is the straw hat ship and this is
where we learn that the crew has been
separated and thus begins the first of
many goals established in the first
episode reconvened with the rest of the
crew reclaimed their ship and booked it
out of there which as it happens is much
more difficult than you'd expect but
more on that later the characters
another reason I typically stay away
from filler material is largely due to
each character's development suddenly
being frozen in place and while that is
largely the case with this because Oda
is sort of a unique case of being one
who likes to have his characters in a
constant state of development
progression and introduction to new
aspects of the world I felt as though g8
offered a ton in the way of allowing
characters to breathe
for a pleasant change we actually got to
just sit back and enjoy them as they are
in various interesting scenarios all the
while also tying the story rather well
with the prior Canon arcs while
utilizing various aspects taken from
that like the dial technology and waiver
which play major roles in this story
helping it to feel more like a natural
progression rather than the detour
technically is there were a number of
characters that surprised me with how
much I actually enjoyed them but none
surprised me more than the head honcho
and Commander of the base itself called
commander Jonathan this naval commander
and part time fishing enthusiast acts as
the main antagonist of the arc and what
makes him interesting to me is that he's
actually one of the most likeable
characters I've yet been introduced to
in this entire series and that's not all
where characters like don krieg Bucky
are along and Bellamy had been fun
brutish characters to overcome head-on
commander Jonathan implements a new
challenge for the straw hats he's
actually an adept strategist which is
fitting as they are in his territory and
he's a high-ranking individual his
laid-back offbeat kind demeanor is a
perfect representation of his combat
ethic also his priority is to first and
foremost causes little harm and to put
his men into his little danger as he can
while also recognizing the good in Luffy
and the others and when it comes to the
others in the group the three that shine
brighter than they normally have for me
have been shopper Musa and Nico Robin
during lead rum Island video I neglected
to talk much about Chopper and really
that's primarily because I didn't really
know yet what to make of him he's very
much a tragic character perhaps more so
than anyone else in the crew but he's
also incredibly reactionary the story
sort of happens to him rather than he
dictates the story which is fine we need
characters like that but I'm usually not
that big a fan of them I mean I think
chopper is fine I like him but he's
nothing special or at least he wasn't to
me I've said before that one of the main
reasons I was impressed with Sanji as a
character was how distinct he felt
despite sharing a ton of similarities
with Zoro's personality that's not an
easy thing to pull off an Oda definitely
does that with Sanji by emphasizing the
elements of his character that are
unique to him without losing sight of
the other aspects we also loved and
while chopper has a very similar dynamic
and that he's very like a Saab he's
smart scared and funny in the
case of chopper I personally haven't
found him nearly as funny as usopp I
don't really get anything out of his
cuteness appeal and whose up is more
interesting when it comes to fights for
me
so unlike sandy the unique attributes
that are distinct to chopper haven't
been for me entertaining enough for him
to stand outside of Aesop's shadow but
I'm happy to say that while watching g8
I actually grew to enjoy his character
much much more than I have in the past
instead of allowing the story to happen
to him once again he insists on taking
the riskier option by staying to help
the wounded crewman of the Naval Base by
defying the typically much stronger
willed Nami that's a decision that is
rich in character and one that was made
and informed by it another aspect that
changed my opinion of chopper was
something much more superficial as I
said a big part of chopper is his
cuteness factor and let me tell you when
he's voiced by the wonderful Otani
famous for voicing Pikachu you best
believe that that cuteness factor starts
to translate and become all the more
apparent at least much more so than it
did when I was reading it on the page
and to be honest the voice acting across
the board was a phenomenal thing to
experience every single performance
brings out the subtleties of each role
in such a believable and natural way
that made me get excited tense and laugh
louder than I have in a very long time
and speaking of which let's talk about
Aesop Moosa is by far and away my
favorite character in this arc at
episode 199 is by far and away the
funniest episode of anime I have ever
seen in my life
the episode surrounds Zeus op and Robin
largely as they attempted to Phi's a
plan to gather Intel and to find the
ship to book it out of there and I love
this dynamic because they are so
intensely different on so many
fundamental levels goose up is loud and
boisterous wanting to prioritize the
retrieval of the ship and Robin is very
subdued eager to gather Intel quietly to
make an educated course of action and
while I love Robins contribution to this
episode and really don't want to devalue
her contribution by perfectly
infiltrating the base under another
person stolen identity
Rousseff's antics vying and scheming in
this one took me on a ride the likes of
which I won't soon forget and it's
largely due to the fantastic script and
delivery of these lines by the voice
actor watching us up in the commander's
office under interrogation crumbling
before his questioning with his only
response being a meek over and over
again honestly had me shrieking with
laughter and so one piece now is the
first anime to make me cry with laughter
as well as the first manga to make me
cry emotionally I've spent a lot of time
trying to describe to you various
aspects of this arc that have impressed
me and really I've come to recognize
this Erika's having and representing a
lot of what made one piece so fun for me
filled to the brim with tremendously
interesting battle scenarios a clear
goal and more character interactions
than most arcs have ever shown us it
takes an expressed interest in
demonstrating to us that not only are
the straw hats not the criminal group
they're made out to be but a sort of
chaotic force of good a whirlwind one
would be lucky to be caught up in one
that enhances and makes better the
places they've been and this arc
highlights that aspect of their dynamic
with each group of characters from the
straw hats wandering and finding their
ways into different facets of the base
elevating and helping each respective
situation and even the commander in
pursuit of them expresses that very
sentiment and once again I'd be lying if
this commander character wasn't the
primary reason as to why I thought this
arc worked as well as it did he begins
his investigation into the abandoned
straw hat shift by gathering information
and through natural means throughout the
story via observations or reports from
his subordinates he's able to take each
piece of information and draw a logical
conclusion from that and so watching as
his plan unfolds is sort of a thing of
beauty surprising not only his personnel
his higher-ups but also Luffy and the
straw hats as he always seems to be one
step ahead of them orchestrated like a
complex game of chess this act of one
piece shares perhaps more in common with
death notes narrative style than any arc
I've seen prior and honestly I'm here
for that and the means with which he is
foiled as both earned and foreshadowed
in him being a fisherman by hobby it's a
very cute act that honestly was so much
better than it had any right to be
utilizing various locations new
characters and establishing lore all in
creative enough ways to make me for
that it was all in inconsequential
filler arc and in addition to that an
aspect of this filler arc that
interested me quite a lot was something
that had brought to my attention that I
glanced over while I was steamrolling my
way through the last Skype via video the
carpenter that fixes up the ship while
they were in Skype hear that ooh sobs aw
who was that I fail to mention it in the
last video but it was mentioned during
this arc and this is quite literally
something I have no idea how to
speculate on who has a vested interest
in the crew success while also having
the ability to get to Skype yet I'm
going to assume I don't have enough
information to go off of but damn who
was that I don't know for sure but one
thing I am sure of is that I am very
glad you all convinced me to take this
welcome detour into g8 I thought it was
a fantastically well executed arc that
really surprised me but that's enough of
that time to get back to the Canon
material with long ring long land eagle
godson two words afro and Luffy iconic
and powerful separately but when
combined form something so immense I
can't look at it for too long without
succumbing to fatigue and bursting into
tears because it's just beautiful this
arc is mostly light-hearted but it's
sandwiched between an intense opening
scene and even more intense conclusion I
mean I can't really call it a conclusion
more like a massive cliffhanger that
makes me want to get done writing this
script so I can start reading the next
installment and what's more is that
within this admittedly light story
there's plenty of tension and
surprisingly touching highlights much
more than I thought there would be so
let's look at what I enjoyed kicking
things off instead of taking up right
where we left off after a Skype yeah
with the straw hats right away we pick
things up with Bellamy and his
subordinate a Jaya only something
horrible is happening and it's due to
one of the newly introduced Ward's of
the sea doflamingo and this scene isn't
playing around where the g-eight arc was
a nice bit of fun this saga starts off
with Bellamy begging for forgiveness as
doflamingo who seems to be controlling
their bodies or actions leads Bellamy to
his unfortunate demise now that's a
powerful and interesting way to kick an
arc off but this as far as I know
doesn't really have anything to do with
the arc itself but perhaps is set up for
what's to come much later regardless of
its purpose it very much establishes
doflamingo as someone that's merciless
and to the point not to mention
dangerous if nothing else this scene has
really made me wonder what even his
power could be as for my point of view
it sort of looks like blood bending from
Avatar The Last Airbender but that's
probably way way off but as I said this
isn't the main point of the arc and once
the scene meets its grim conclusion we
pick up with the straw hats once again
as they come across a ship that seems to
be on low morale know-how and supplies
all before they land on this new island
filled with long things I mean I write
for a living and I don't know how else
to best describe it there's a lot of
long things on this island long and tall
but what I liked about this opening was
that instead of setting a goal it poses
a question to the viewer
why was there a ship so ill-equipped out
there oftentimes stories like to
establish a goal of an ark right away
but doing this time it again can get
sort of predictable so establishing a
question is a nice change of pace for
this instance
once on this strange Island the crew
splits into two groups one led by Luffy
who bounds on to the island looking to
explore and the other half stay at the
ship to take care of it and both groups
encounter their own odd individuals
Luffy's group arrives and comes across a
house and help an old man off of some
super tall stills that he's been stuck
atop for 10 years which in and of itself
is ridiculous but what's more is that
his horse that shaped like a giraffe
waited for him all that time because he
loved him which gave me serious Futurama
vibes flashing me back to that time
Fry's dog waited for him until he died
though admittedly I thought that story
was much more sad which is good as I
don't think this old man character is
here for any other reason than to
provide the straw hat someone to protect
or to avenge as his horse ends up being
shot by the individuals which this arc
deals with primarily the group that
approaches the crew on the ship is
called the foxy pirates led by the
wonderfully designed foxy the Silver Fox
I'm always interested in seeing how
these overly cartoonish villains are
designed by Oda just by looking at this
guy you can tell exactly what he's about
and that's just the sign of a great
design and it's during this section we
are given an answer to that question
posed at the very beginning of this
story as well as given two separate
goals to work towards as a reader or
viewer help the old guy find his way
back to his tribe that left him behind
because he was on stills for 10 years
and defeat the foxy pirates in this
jewel day proposed after shooting his
horse in the leg now first things first
the duel more specifically this is
called a Davy back fight and in this
instance it's a three-part challenge
that includes a race a ball game and a
combat section and overall I enjoyed it
I thought it was somewhat predictable in
a lot of ways but there was just enough
for me to sink my teeth into with the
first two rounds with the third and
final round genuinely surprisingly for
the better but I'll get into that a
little bit later what makes these Davy
back fights interesting in the first
place are the rules and stakes that come
packaged with them interference is
allowed there are no substitutes and
whoever wins gets to select either the
flag of that crew or their crew member
to join your forces for keeps these
create much higher stakes than I
expected and as I pointed out earlier
the incentive to fight on behalf of the
old man was there for the characters
although I personally didn't have much
of a connection to him myself but hey
I'm willing to
some games of skill for fun and with
that the teams are divvied up round one
the donut race is Nico Robin Musa and
Nami round two the ball game or the
groggy ring C's Oro teaming up with
chopper and Sanji and finally round
three is a compact section which sees
monkey D Luffy versus the captain of the
foxy pirates silver fox and what's
interesting is that each of these
sections has something narrative Li
going on to help keep us engaged so
let's look at how these worked and see
where their shortcomings were if they
had any first up round one the donut
race I found this race to be quite fun
imaginative and with just the right
amount of stress it reminded me of the
old Wacky Races cartoons from back in
the day and I mean that in the best
possible way much like that old show
this race involves a good guy team and a
clear bad guy team that every available
opportunity uses underhanded tactics to
force the odds into their favor in
addition to being pretty much better
prepared for this contest and in
addition to having a crew member that is
a fish person their captain and boss
from the sidelines does everything in
his power to force the misdirection of
the straw hats and that's essentially
the meat and potatoes of the narrative
setup for this race see her team
struggle and sacrifice their personal
health through clever uses of impact
dial all to lose the edge because of
some cheap tactic bills of frustration
that not only forces us to desire
justice for the straw hats and winning
but also establishes and bills off the
foxy crew as someone we audience really
want to see get their comeuppance and
that's what the entire point of this
race actually is narrative Lee speaking
it's meant to make us hate them and boy
did it watching his Nami
oh stop and Robin struggled to overcome
various obstacles in their little
last-minute watercraft while taking a
commanding lead because of their
knowledge and grit only to have them
lose at the last possible second due to
one of the cheapest tricks I've ever
seen a devil fruit power that gives the
captain of their crew the ability to
shoot a beam at someone to make them
move slowly made my blood boil and it's
supposed to the goal of this race was to
essentially establish who these people
really are and why we want Luffy and the
rest of them to dominate in the later
rounds but what's worse is that not only
have we lost this round but we also lose
a valued crew member of the straw hats
and this is a particularly difficult
thing to watch as we've seen all of the
individual stories this ragtag group of
misfits have shown us
to see one of them get torn away from
them is heartbreaking specifically
because the one that ultimately gets
taken away is chopper and now it's time
to see if they can win him back
it's time for round two the groggy ring
with Zorro and Sanjay because chopper
was taken in the prior round the team of
Sanjay and Zorro are now faced with a
two on three disadvantage without the
ability to substitute once again light
the last round with the race the good
guy team is at an obvious disadvantage
from the get-go and that's ignoring the
more glaring aspects that are working
against them the imagery during this
introductory portion is fantastic shown
in a domineering fashion dwarfing the
straw hats
the imagery really communicates a David
versus Goliath type scenario and reminds
me a lot of the imagery from Dragon Ball
Akira Toriyama loved to draw kid Goku in
a very small way pitted up against these
massive opponents as this makes it all
the more satisfying to see when Goku
would eventually topple these imposing
foes but one aspect of this contest that
made no sense to me was the notion that
interference was allowed but they aren't
allowed to field a third player
what if someone consistently interfered
say like as much as a player in a match
would I mean I don't know I found that
to be sort of self contradictory but the
real story behind this particular round
isn't necessarily the straw hats
overcoming the enemy team in this
exchange though that's definitely part
of it the real story is instead made
more interesting because of Sanjay and
Zoro's notoriously ill-fitted dynamic
and that is very much the case in this
contest between getting on each other's
nerves and in each other's way the two
straw hats get beaten to a pulp
partially because they are being cheated
but also because they can't harmonize
but in a momentary truce for 10 seconds
their combined efforts humiliate and
destroy the opposing team which was
incredibly cathartic and they ended up
getting chopper back - which is always
good news which finally brings us to the
third and final round of the Davey back
fight monkey D Luffy versus captain's
silver fox the pomp and ceremony that
builds up this event between these two
in this final round is so funny
obviously after foxy threw underhanded
means fixes the location of the fight
stalls food March stands and even
bleachers all get set up as the two
begin to enter the ring stage to do
combat whoever knocks their opponent
outside of the 100 meter circle wins in
Luffy's quarter is Usopp and thanks to
his help Luffy comes
looking fittingly ridiculous Rousseff
also is the absolute perfect person to
have in Lupe's corner as a height man
and the way that he talks Luffy into
wearing an afro is honestly inspired but
if I'm being perfectly honest with this
final fight I wasn't expecting anything
significant I was expecting some
slapstick humour some quick thinking but
for Luffy to eventually get the better
of him and all that does happen on a
number of occasions as Luffy deals with
the unfair odds stacked against him by
this fittingly fiendish foxy tried to
overcome his ridiculously powerful devil
free ability and even more trouble below
deck involving a giant robot and a
mirror trick but what's interesting to
me anyway is the relentless nature of
this fight it begins in a light-hearted
place but eventually as the fight
escalates the bloody body of Luffy falls
on the floor time and time again and
typically this is where the rule of
three comes into effect typically
speaking a lot of story beats come in
threes as do jokes for that matter
usually with the third instance
something repeats there's a significant
difference that turns the tide of that
pattern but with this fight Luffy falls
to the floor way more than three times
and each and every time he drags himself
to his feet each time slower than the
last
suddenly as an audience we stop looking
at this fight as something light-hearted
and realized that Luffy is hurting
immensely and that's when we see this
throughout this chapter and fight
various characters make note of luffy's
deteriorating condition
foxy his crew and eventually even the
straw hats who up until this instance
had been firmly in the corner of Luffy
thinking that he could never lose to
this joker but when faced with their
friend their captain beaten into a
motionless heap on the floor even they
have to recognize it but once again
despite being on the verge of losing
more than just this match Luffy staggers
to his feet once again declaring without
a hint of reluctancy or uncertainty
I won't lose a single member of my crew
even if it kills me what an absolute
champion and with this defiance stand
before his maker legs shaking breathing
uneven but with an unmatched
determination spurring him on even Foxx
his crew began to get behind Luffy which
is a very sweet visual but as I said
it's breaking this rule of three that
makes us as an audience feel more
uneasy about this fight and reinforced
by the imagery as well as witnessing the
ones always nimble Luffy barely managed
to move without falling to the floor is
what he's hit by yet another attack this
time more massive than all the rest and
so seeing him stand once again starts to
feel uncomfortable
not to mention unpredictable especially
when you know the lengths he's willing
to go to and perhaps the most worrying
thing about this is that luffy was
genuinely at his limit and was about to
lose had it not been for a complete
fluke a random shard of the mirror from
earlier in the fight had become lodged
in his afro reflecting the beam back at
foxy before luffy had time to deal the
finishing blow finally taking the win
for something to finally go their way in
this absurdly unfair contest was a nice
change of pace and to see foxy finally
get his comeuppance was incredibly
cathartic also far more than I thought
it was going to be - and perhaps very
fittingly it was the power of the hair -
that won the day and so closing the book
on this chapter Luffy takes the Jolly
Roger and gives it to the old man as a
symbol that those that doubt the deed to
his horse have been taken care of but
perhaps the most interesting part of
this chapter is still to come and it
comes in the form of this gentleman
[Music]
the appearance of this man and the
tension dissection brings I was not
prepared for as it's totally in contrast
with predominantly the rest of this arc
once he appeared
I knew something serious is about to
happen and the expression that falls
across Robins face was all that I needed
to reinforce that notion someone who had
been incredibly calm and collected no
matter the circumstances in the past now
had a massive worry painted right across
her face
as it happens apparently this guy is one
of the four most powerful and
highest-ranking individuals in the Navy
and man does it show and once again I
want to draw attention to all his
characterization of this guy
it's very tempting to just write a
brutish or stereotypical character but
he takes the time to establish him
someone with his lazy demeanor and
mannerisms on top of that he
demonstrates a devil free power to help
the old man cross the ocean to find his
tribe and that power is fittingly suited
to his icy chill personality he
introduces himself as a lackey gee and
what's more as he makes a passing remark
that Luffy is just like his grandpa but
more importantly that both he and Robin
need to die before things get out of
hand with them and the means with which
he takes out Robin without hesitation is
terrifying and comes out of nowhere
without her so much as even being able
to put up a resistance thankfully though
the crews detour away in time to thaw
her believing Luffy the most capable
among them to deal with the strange new
character but even he is no match firm
and with relative ease this naval higher
up leaves Luffy frozen and completely
outmatched it's like he wasn't even
really trying the ending of this arc
left me with a strange feeling over the
last 300 or so chapters Luffy has been
proving himself to be far more
formidable than anyone thought he was
and the people he's proven himself to
have been far more than just the
villains he's found himself up against
he shown himself to be a person people
can rely on when all the chips are down
primarily to his crew over a number of
instances various crew members have made
passing remarks regarding how they don't
need to worry about Luffy that he's more
than capable that he
at hand but in this arc are not just one
but two separate occasions Luffy would
have lost in dramatic fashion had he not
been lucky and so while this arc was
largely light-hearted there was a really
humanizing message at its core that
Luffy has his limits that Luffy can be
defeated and even though he might want
to save everyone Luffy might not be able
to and that's my biggest takeaway from
this arc before I move into water 7 next
week to say that I am extremely excited
to see what's to come in this story is
an understatement with the knowledge now
that the Maine Navy HQ is in the region
they're heading towards next and that
they are fully aware of what Luffy did
to crocodile I'm very interested to see
how this new dynamic works with the
straw hats and more specifically from a
narrative perspective as in this act we
have reminded that the Navy are in fact
individuals with good intentions they
unlike the rest of the villains we've
come up against thus far want to help
people to do good which matches Luffy's
philosophy and that's not even to
mention how da Flamingo and the other
warlords of the sea play into all of
this and I still have no idea what that
mysterious repairman in sky Pia was
doing or who he was
I'm thoroughly pumped to see what comes
next and I can't wait to review it for
you guys next week I'm tackling water 7
so wish me luck but that'll do it for
this video I've been totally not mark
I'll see you all next week and thank you
so much for watching